pour l'institut israélien de la
démocratie un organisme indépendant de
surveillance basée en israël
il s'agit bien d'une violation des
droits de l'homme selon cette
organisation cela ne correspond pas à
l'esprit des lois fondamentales
le gouvernement défend cependant sa
position en tant que la santé des
citoyens film sur la liberté des
citoyens visés que cette interdiction de
visas cry loiret a autorisé la
circulation afin que le virus de la
cause une bonne pause dans le hall des
arrivées de l'aéroport bendjillali
controverse qui a vécu avec
l'introduction de bracelet de
surveillance électronique
arrivant sur le sol israélien ont le
choix entre se mettre en quarantaine
dans des hôtels gérés par l'armée on a
signalé des faits affreux tels que le
viol d'une jeune fille de 13 ans un
manque de nourriture ou
d'infrastructures ils ont le choix entre
ces hôtels gérés par l'armée ou par une
quarantaine à domicile pour s'assurer
qu'ils respecteront la quarantaine à
domicile ils devront désormais porter un
bracelet à la cheville ou poney
l'interdiction d'entrer dans le pays
devraient être assouplies
mais on ne sait pas encore vraiment
c'est la politique du bracelet
électronique va continuer la cour
suprême israélienne vient de décider de
limiter la capacité j'ai le service de
sécurité intérieure le shin bet à
contrôler les déplacements d'individus
via leur téléphone
les maladies dues coronavirus sont
surveillés afin de s'assurer qu'ils ne
propagent pas la maladie la question est
donc combien de temps encore cela
sera-t-il possible
le comité central des élections a
tranché aujourd'hui que les israéliens
hors du pays ne pourront voter lors des
élections parlementaires du vin
mars les seules personnes qui seront
autorisés à voter auprès des ambassades
seront les personnes travaillant pour
des organisations israéliennes juives et
à l'étranger pour des raisons
professionnelles tout comme lors des
trois dernières élections
selon les chiffres du gouvernement vingt
une personnes à l'étranger soit rentré
pour voter ce ne sont pas les effectifs
susceptible d'avoir une influence sur
les résultats du vote
les personnes rentrer en israël
il s'agit encore une fois de chiffres du
gouvernement sont surtout des ultra
orthodoxes des juifs haredim
traditionnellement ils votent à droite
les israéliens rentrant apporterait donc
leur soutien au parti de droite
d'après les dernières prévisions le camp
qui netanyahu obtiendrait 60 sièges sur
les 120 du parlement et le camp pro
netanyahu bien moins sont vachement
correct et le camp anti netanyahu réussi
à former une coalition
le premier ministre israélien qui a
occupé le plus longtemps son poste
pourrait bien se retrouver au chômage